hello we begin with the corona virus
outbreak in China that's showing no
signs of letting up so in the past few
hours Hong Kong's leader Carrie Lam
announced a series of drastic new
measures including halting ferry and
train services to the mainland having
the number of flights and suspension of
personal travel permits Lam is also
urging all Hong Kong residents to remain
at home for the next 14 days Lloyd a
young Hong Kong the measures will be
effective in reducing the number of
visitors from the mainland
since transportation services are
required for the commuters we will scale
back our transportation services first
of all high-speed rail services to and
from the mainland will be suspended in
terms of air travel the number of
flights from mainland to Hong Kong will
be slashed by half in terms of sea
travel all cross-border ferry services
will be suspended Adrian Brown has more
on the impact of those new measures I
think a lot of legislators here in Hong
Kong in the opposition camp are
certainly saying it's too little too
late let's put this into some sort of
context this is one of the busiest
frontiers in the world 40 million people
crossed over it last year just 2 million
for instance in November and that's in
spite of these ongoing political
protests which have a strong anti
mainland sentiment to them and that anti
mainland sentiment has been you know
feeding into what's been going on for
the past week here in Hong Kong that
virus is really stirring up an anti
mainland mood here in Hong Kong the
border of course is absolutely crucial
70 people in Hong Kong work in the
mainland they they go over in the
morning come home in the evening that's
now effectively going to stop now she
has stopped short of declaring a total
closure of the border this is a partial
closure rail and ferry links are being
cut the number of flights between Hong
Kong and the mainland are being hard and
that's really gonna hit airlines like
Cathay Pacific at a time when they're
already being squeezed economically
because of the ongoing protests now
Carol Ann has also lamented the fact
that there has been a lot of
misinformation she says online
suggesting that Hong Kong was having to
rely on the mainland for help
and also the other way around she says
that's simply not the case well Carrie
lambs move appears to be an attempt to
further insulate Hong Kong from the
outbreak which has now killed a hundred
and six people while more than four and
a half thousand Chinese are infected and
the virus has spread widely right across
Southeast Asia there are 14 confirmed
cases in Thailand and 8 in Hong Kong
it's also been found in Taiwan Macau
South Korea Japan Singapore Malaysia
Vietnam and Cambodia and elsewhere in
the world cases have been confirmed in
Germany in France in Nepal Australia the
US as well as Canada and many of those
countries are working to get their
citizens out of the Chinese city of
Wuhan that's at the epicenter of the
outbreak but the World Health
Organization has warned of the risks of
evacuation evacuating staff or any
anybody from an area always bears the
slight possibility that they carry the
virus with them or especially if there's
a possibility of asymptomatic
or very small lights symptoms at the
same time I understand that countries
who have been already talking about
bringing their nationals back which is
of course in the full sovereignty in the
interest of those member states have
been taking measures or have announced
measures to either contain these people
on the on the way back or contain for a
certain amount of time let's discuss the
virus and these measures that have been
taken with Marc Eccleston Turner who's a
lecturer of global health law at the
University of Kiel in the UK and that is
in fact where he's joining us from
thanks very much for your time with us
on al-jazeera and I know that you are
most probably keeping an eye out on the
situation over in China and Hong Kong so
first address these measures that Hong
Kong has taken to enforce a sort of
partial closure on its borders and
China's restricting transportation do
these measures work or are they too
little too late they typically don't
work no they they tend to to not provide
any real public health benefit and
border closures tend to happen during
during any sort
novel outbreak like this that we see and
very and the evidence that they they
actually have any benefit on the public
health responses is very very limited
and there is an old adage in public
health that diseases don't respect
borders and and it's very much true if
and because of the interconnected nature
of the world it's unsurprising to see
cases pop up in new countries away from
away from China and away from Wuhan and
people who wish to to cross borders and
people who wish to lead cordon sanitaire
like we're seeing in which is in place
in in Wuhan now we'll find the means to
do so and the other issue is is as you
rightly suggest the horse is already
bolted them if spread has occurred it's
probably already occurred and these
measures and are quite restrictive quite
regressive and they they usually serve
to create fear in community rather than
rather than actually provide any real
concrete public health benefit so what
sort of measures then would you be
recommending so some things which which
there is an evidence base for which
which provide which are effective are
what are call social distancing measures
so these can slow down the spread of a
virus although you know not stop it so
things like suspending schools
suspending mass gatherings in some
instances suspending public transport
but the main the main thing which which
will work is public health preparedness
is having strong and robust health
systems which are able to respond to
novel outbreaks as and when they occur
that is the only thing which really
works and it is not possible to prevent
viruses from moving around the globe
what the only thing which is possible is
being able to quickly respond to them
when they when they do so
so that means having in place rapid
diagnostic testing to actually identify
whether people do have corona virus or
not so at this time of year in the in
the northern hemisphere lots of people
have the sort of symptoms which could
appear to be corona virus but it's
almost certainly not it's almost
certainly caused by something else so
things like influenza
common cold give fairly similar symptoms
to to the coronavirus so knowing whether
people actually have this and
coronavirus or something else is the
first thing that we need to do the
second thing we need to do is be able to
treat those people and in isolation when
they do when they are symptomatic or
when they do have the virus to ensure
that there is a limited on would spread
okay we'll have to leave it there we
thank you very much for speaking to us
from the UK thank you